[Música]
de la presidencia la cárcel de la cárcel
de nuevo a la presidencia también
sobreviviente del cáncer viudo
sindicalista y figura Internacional de
la izquierda Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
es el nuevo presidente electo de Brasil
después de una jornada que se desarrolló
sin mayores contratiempos pero tuvo un
muy muy ajustado resultado veamos con el
100% de los votos el tse certificó que
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva del partido
de los trabajadores obtuvo el 50,9% de
los votos es decir 60 millones
345,999 votos en segundo lugar como les
digo con un estrecho margen está Yair
bolsonaro del pl quien obtuvo el
49,1%, unos 59 millones
206.354 votos
en su primer discurso saludo brasileños
Lula habló de unidad consciente por
supuesto de esa gran polarización que
atraviesa el país también habló de medio
ambiente del resurgimiento de la
economía brasileña a través de una nueva
industrialización habló de la igualdad
entre mujeres y hombres etcétera y a
combatir también el hambre eso también
hizo un llamado muy claro habló de un
Brasil líder en la región y líder en el
mundo un discurso lleno de promesas que
ahora muchos se preguntan qué tan
realizable es en la práctica escuchemos
la mayoría de los brasileños dejó Claro
que quiere más no menos democracia
Brasil es mi prioridad la gente es mi
causa y luchar contra la miseria es para
lo que viviré hasta el final de mi vida
el pueblo es mi causa con esa frase
terminó el presidente electo sus
discurso su primer discurso tras darse a
conocer estos resultados oficiales de
otra parte el actual presidente y quien
aspiraba a la reelección Jair bolsonaro
no se ha manifestado frente a estos
resultados su silencio genera todo tipo
de incertidumbre también hay muchas
especulaciones en torno a las razones
que podría tener bolsonaro para haber
guardado silencio y no haber hablado
sobre los resultados que valga decir si
bien bolsonaro no ganó en la votación es
muy representativo que perdió con cerca
de 58 millones de votos es muy
significativo el papel que ha tenido la
derecha en estos comicios
para analizar Cómo se organizará
entonces la derecha con este nuevo
gobierno será una fórmula de oposición
contra el gobierno de Lula da Silva
también da para analizar Qué significa
para la región el viraje político que da
Brasil ese nuevo bloque de izquierda
continental que se conforma puntos para
analizar pues múltiples por eso Entonces
entremos en materia y para conversar
sobre esta jornada electoral en Brasil y
lo que viene para este país suramericano
hemos invitado a Paulo Velasco él es
profesor de política Internacional de la
Universidad del estado de Río de Janeiro
y también está con nosotros Leonardo
magalash él es especialista en opinión
pública y relaciones públicas también
cuenta con una phd en comunicación
política y también hace parte de la
organización latinoamérica 21 ustedes
nuestros televidentes también hacen
parte del debate pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales ustedes ya lo saben
estamos en Twitter en Facebook y en
instagram nos encuentran como arroba el
debate guión bajo 24 arrobas antilogo
que es mi cuenta personal la etiqueta
para que dejen sus comentarios numeral
el debate f24 todos los contenidos de
nuestro programa también están
disponibles en podcast lo pueden
encontrar en Apple podcast en Spotify en
deezer y en TuneIn
le doy entonces la bienvenida a Pablo
Velasco para comenzar a conocer
opiniones sobre esta jornada electoral
Pablo Muchas gracias por estar con
nosotros hoy en el programa y Punto de
partida la pregunta inicial del debate
porque Lula porque Brasil vuelve a votar
a Luis Ignacio Lola da Silva
Hola Santiago encantado de no hablar con
ustedes Bueno yo creo que eso refleja
mucho también lo que es el
antibolsionalismo no un Brasil muy
dividido muy polarizado muchos que han
votado por Lula en realidad no lo votan
tanto por convicción por lo que
representa Pero porque tienen miedo de
lo que representa bolsonaro en términos
de ataques a la democracia hay que
reconocer por ejemplo de que Lula ha
conseguido a lo largo sobre todo de las
últimas cuatro semanas entre la primera
y la segunda vuelta ha conseguido un
frente amplio que es lo que se soñaba es
lo que se decía en Brasil y es con lo
que se soñaba en Brasil que hace ya
muchos meses por ejemplo hay que
recordar el apoyo dado explícitamente
por el expresidente Cardoso a Lula y
muchos de los economistas que estuvieron
al lado de Cardoso que representan lo
que es la centro derecha tradicional
brasileña entonces Lula consigue ganar
las elecciones por este estrecho margen
que has comentado has comentado el
margen estrecho de la historia política
brasileña desde la red demócracia se
hace ya más de 30 años entonces claro
supone un intento de cambio para que las
cosas se hagan un poco diferente de lo
que se hicieron en estos últimos cuatro
años la opinión de Pablo nuestro primer
invitado ahora saludo a Leonardo también
allí en la ciudad de Río de Janeiro
Leonardo Bienvenido al programa y El
Punto de partida porque Lula porque
Brasil vuelve a elegir a Lula para un
tercer mandato también hay que decirlo
Muchas gracias Santiago Muchas gracias
Pablo Buenas tardes
saludo también al público de Francia 24
el duda es el sin dudas el más grande
líder político de Brasil y es el que
tiene digamos el más grande electorado
cautivo y es importante decir que la
elección de duda en su tercer mandato
viene con cuatro años de retraso porque
en el 2018
Buda ha sido impedido en participar de
la elección por
una decisión judicial
muy discutible en el que el juez que lo
que lo juzgó con una sentencia donde no
es posible leer una una prueba siquiera
no en contra de él en la sentencia él se
volvió luego ministro de justicia y en
esta elección apoyo entonces
Saluda en 2000 en 2018 tenía más de 60%
de intención de Voto y fue retirado de
la contienda electoral no y ahora llega
finalmente en su tercer mandato y es
importante decir también que es no es
una elección donde ganó la democracia no
ganó solamente a la izquierda sino en
realidad es más correcto decir que ganó
ganó la democracia Pero quien como decía
justamente Pablo
observamos el más grande frente amplio
desde la red de democratización del país
sin duda será el líder ideal para poder
vencer a un fascismo que viene creciendo
en el país no con aspiraciones
abiertamente golpistas no se trata
solamente de
de interpretaciones sino que hay
declaraciones muy explícitas de
bolsonaro y de sus aliados
intentos golpistas también no entonces
duda fue la figura ideal para poder
vencer a ese movimiento fascista que
viene crecía de Brasil Leonardo usted
habla de Lula como un gran político en
la escena brasileña también es un
político muy destacado a nivel
internacional pero prácticamente hace
unos cuatro años Lula se le había dado
por finalizado su su correría política
ya había finalizado estuvo en la cárcel
lo decía yo al inicio de el programa
Pero hay una especie de resurgimiento de
resurrección de esta figura política Qué
significa este resurgimiento de Lula en
la escena política brasileña
significa que
incluso
los procesos que sufrió no impactaron
completamente en la popularidad y en la
memoria positiva de estado de bienestar
y prosperidad
de sus dos gobiernos
duda
cuando estuve en la cárcel su
popularidad en las encuestas bajo
bastantes su imagen positiva bajo
bastante pero
desde el momento en el que lo
inocentaron no el Tribunal Superior el
supremo tribunal Federal lo inocentó
su popularidad empezó automáticamente a
crecer no quien hace trekking Yo hace
tres años en ese momento un par de días
después su popularidad empezó a crecer y
recuperó
la imagen positiva que tenía antes con
lo cual
gustó mucho Sobre que sí era la muerte
política de duda por por el sentimiento
anti corrupción pero hoy incluso
conmocionaron que también es acusado de
corrupción y en su familia vemos que el
tema del anticorrupción era más como una
una excusa para justificar un
sentimiento antipista y los sentimientos
de
infelicidad en relación a la situación
del país no eres Quizás es una temática
más profunda no el tema de la corrupción
tenemos
hoy en día tan relevante o por lo menos
es una excusa que utiliza la gente no si
no fuera a de esa forma No saldría no
hubiera salido elegido y hemos sonado
tampoco tendría la votación que tiene Sí
en esas primeras declaraciones que dio
el presidente electo a los brasileños
hizo un llamado a la unidad resaltó
Paulo que no hay dos brasiles no hay
solamente un país pero es un discurso
lleno de promesas qué tan realizable es
este tipo de anuncios que hizo el
presidente electo anoche para los
brasileños teniendo en cuenta el
contexto social del país el contexto
económico y el contexto internacional
Bueno yo creo que ha sido un llamamiento
muy importante a la unidad en
un escenas de Santiago muy dividido muy
polarizado es decir empezar de esa
manera significa que no ha sido
exactamente un discurso de la Victoria
ha sido un discurso de estadista ha sido
un discurso más parecido a lo que será
el discurso de Posesión el día 1 de
enero Brasil tiene que efectivamente
pasar por un proceso que no será nada
fácil de unidad nacional y es por eso
también pasa mucho de los retos que
enfrentará el presidente nula
se va a enfrentar a un parlamento muy
conservador donde muchos escaños están
con la centro derecha incluso con la
extrema derecha que ha crecido muchísimo
en Brasil y la verdad este parlamento no
le va a hacer la vida nada fácil a la
luna tendrá que usar mucho de su
habilidad política su capacidad de
diálogo político para intentar llevar a
cabo muchos de los proyectos que tiene y
muchas de las promesas que ha hecho el
día de ayer pero no lo tiene nada fácil
de Brasil vive todavía un escenario de
incertidumbre
Aunque ha caído un poquito la inflación
y ha disminuido un poquito el paro pero
todavía tenemos un reto muy grande hay
que equilibrar las cuentas en bolsonar o
abandonado por completo cualquier
disciplina fiscal en los últimos meses
para intentar ganar las elecciones
entonces he hecho gastos absolutamente
absurdos que se tendrán que pagar y
seguramente lo hará el próximo gobierno
a partir de enero entonces la situación
económica no es nada buena para Brasil y
bueno la situación internacional también
es muy complicada mucho peor de la que
encontró hace 20 años cuando ganó las
elecciones en el 2002 en aquel entonces
luna tenía un escenario más favorable
tanto dentro cuanto fuera del país y
ahora no lo tienes es decir hay que ver
De cuánto de lo que ha prometido ayer
tendrá condiciones de realizarlo pero
fue un discurso vamos que se entiende en
el sentido de que la sociedad brasileña
confía en él y que vuelva a unirse ahora
que se ha terminado a esta contienda
electoral que ha sido tan dura y tan
violenta en muchos momentos Paulo
continuó con usted dejó la mesa Paulo
Leonardo el tema económico el tema de
Brasil a nivel internacional para
tratarlo en unos minutos y quiero que
nos enfoquemos en el tema de la unidad
Cómo comenzar a construir unidad a nivel
social y también a nivel político todo
esto de cara como usted dice Pablo de
tener un parlamento completamente
dividido que le va a costar mucho tratar
de generar consensos allí pero Lula se
ha caracterizado por ser un político que
dialoga y se acerca eso lo ha demostrado
a lo largo de estos años y para esto
último mes de campaña que trató de
generar consensos con con el centro
también qué tan fácil tiene ese diálogo
con el parlamento para conseguir esas
coaliciones o acercarse y para poner a
dialogar en buenos términos a los
brasileños
bueno Luna tiene que acercarse a varios
sectores en el parlamento claro ahí
podemos decir alrededor de 90 casi 100
bolsos bolsonaristas más radicales
podemos decir con los que tendrá la vida
muy difícil para establecer cualquier
tipo de diálogo de entendimiento de
Alianza pero tiene a su lado también
alrededor de 80 a 80 y pico diputados de
un frente de izquierda de una Federación
de izquierda claro liderada por el p10
que seguramente siempre estarán a su
lado entonces me sobran alrededor de 300
diputados con los que podrán si
establecer algún tipo de diálogo son
diputados en su gran mayoría más de
centros centro de derecha pero que vamos
el mula si hay un personaje político que
está acostumbrado a dialogar y a buscar
este tipo de entendimiento
con su habilidad política y que ya ha
demostrado en tantos momentos a lo largo
de los últimos 30 años pues podrán
establecer algún tipo de conexión es
importante también que haga algunos
guiños al mercado todavía no se sabe
quién será
suministro de economía
o hemos visto de una incertidumbre en el
mercado en Brasil la bolsa de valores ha
subido un poquito Entonces es importante
que ya en las próximas semanas
de economía para tranquilizar el mercado
la banca Y que todos entiendan que va a
mantener una responsabilidad fiscal y
económica qué es lo que hizo incluso
sobre todo en su primer gobierno cuando
mantuvo muy claramente la política que
venía del gobierno Cardoso y Leonardo
Cuál es su opinión sobre esta necesidad
de generar consensos y necesidad de
poner a los brasileños a dialogar en
buenos términos
Santiago creo que ningún analista serio
tiene la ilusión de que va a ser un
gobierno muy de izquierdas no duda es
como como dijeron ustedes justamente es
un político muy conciliador sabe
negociar sabe acercarse no ya lo hizo en
el pasado cuando tenía un fin más margen
no de maniobra política no pero ahora
logró elegirse con un frente bastante
amplio y va a tener que pactar mucho más
se va a tener que ceder mucho más no
Entonces es muy probable que sea un
gobierno bastante centrista con una
mirada social Pero Un gobierno
que tuvieron de 20 centrista porque se
comprometió políticamente con algunas
figuras que lo ayudaron con la
maquinaria de partido con la maquinaria
propia de
como personas de sus legiones para poder
hacer campaña presencial no Y eso cuenta
mucho en una elección principalmente
principalmente en una lección tan
apretada como fue
la que luego dio ese resultado de es
solamente un por ciento de diferencia
entre Lula y bolso pero es importante
también decir que si todo dado la
capacidad de negociación es importante
para mantener estable el gobierno por
otro lado para
poder ganar la próxima elección y
acercarse a la población
quizás hay que pensar en una estrategia
un poco diferente no Quizás
diferenciando lo que son los discursos y
lo que son algunas prácticas políticas
un poco en los moldes de lo que hacía
bolsonaro que quizás radicalizaba un
poco en el discurso y en la práctica por
pactando también principalmente la
segunda etapa de su gobierno porque digo
eso porque es hay un fenómeno que es
común es común en los Estados Unidos es
común en Europa y ahora es común también
en Latinoamérica que las izquierdas
que están como traumadas y terminar
huyéndose al centro puede recibir muchas
críticas de ser cercanas a proyectos
socialistas y proyectos autoritarios
se transformaron en partidos y en grupos
que son más prosistema
no están contentas con el sistema
automáticamente van a criticar esos
partidos
lo interrumpo por acá porque tengo para
hablar el tema de las campañas y el
discurso de los dos candidatos y el
presidente electo Para que lo miremos un
poco más adelante resérveme esa idea ahí
para tratar la más adelante quiero
tratar el tema económico Pablo es un
tema muy delicado la situación a nivel
mundial y el tema a nivel local en
Brasil pues es delicado también y Tal
parece que la fórmula que le funcionó
muy bien a Lula en su primer y segundo
mandato no va a poder ser la misma
fórmula que aplique para este tercer
mandato Aquí hay una gran necesidad de
volver a sacar a millones de personas de
la pobreza en un proceso que sea
revirtió en un proceso que dio marcha
atrás y acabar con el hambre que es un
problema que ahora está quedando en
evidencia en este país
y sobre todo él toca un punto importante
y es hacer ver a Brasil no como un país
extractivista sino como un país
tecnológico en cuatro años se logra eso
Bueno es un reto enorme muy difícil
sobre todo porque claro la situación
internacional
no es muy favorable a este tipo de
proyecto a este tipo de iniciativa
cuando fue presidente por primera vez
hace 20 años la realidad internacional
le favorecía muchísimo No ahora no Claro
son cuestiones urgentes muy importantes
y es muy muy importante que lo las deje
ya muy claras desde el primer día de la
victoria en su discurso ya justo después
de ganar Brasil en efecto le ha vivido
una última década desastrosa terrible es
una década perdida en efecto entonces
hay que invertir todos los esfuerzos
posibles para disminuir la pobreza en el
país disminuir la desigualdad y sobre
todo disminuir el número de personas con
hambre no son más de 30 millones de
brasileños que tienen hambre a día de
hoy entonces claro son cuestiones muy
urgentes pero
no tendrá la facilidad tuvo hace 20 años
porque ya no tenemos el mismo nivel de
crecimiento económico en China
ya no seguimos el Boom de las comoditas
por lo menos no como se había dado en
aquel entonces la realidad internacional
es una realidad muy desfavorable no
solamente por la guerra en Ucrania Pero
porque hay una situación de recesión
económica
vamos muy
grave en Europa por ejemplo ya muchos
países por ahí acercándose a una
recesión entonces son retos que le
complican mucho la vida
si le sumamos a todo eso las
dificultades que tendrá dentro del
parlamento pues vemos que la situación
política
en nada sencilla Leonardo pasó al tema
internacional el presidente electo habló
de esa necesidad de volver a poner a
Brasil en el escenario internacional de
volver a ser un actor importante y
destacado vimos también que muchos
presidentes mandatarios de América
Latina y de el resto del mundo lo
preguntaron se mostraron todos muy
abiertos a tratar diferentes temas a
trabajar en conjunto Pero hay muchas
preguntas sobre cómo lograr ese
reposicionamiento de Brasil a nivel
internacional a nivel internacional que
tanto tiene Brasil Para ofrecerle al
resto del mundo en una economía en
recesión y sumamente competitiva y
también hay preguntas sobre qué posición
va a tener el frente a gobiernos como el
de Daniel Ortega como el de Nicolás
maduro o como el de Miguel Díaz canel
presidentes que también hay que decir
también lo felicitaron y se mostraron
muy alegres por su triunfo
sí Muchos precedentes muchos líderes de
estado no
felicitaron duda muy rápidamente con
menos de una hora desde el momento de en
el que el tc confirmó su Victoria en la
segunda vuelta y duda siempre ha tenido
un perfil de diálogo con cualquier tipo
de gobierno de no entrometerse en la
política interna de los países en
algunos casos incluso apoyar
elecciones de algunos aliados no
principalmente de izquierdas lo que
generó también algunas polémicas no en
el caso de Nicolás maduro Por ejemplo yo
también Ortega Ortega también no la
línea de la política exterior va a ser
muy pragmática en ese sentido
seguramente nos va a criticar
abiertamente
presidentes de la religión primero
porque hay relaciones también de Alianza
con estos países no y segundo porque no
es su perfil no A diferencia de
bolsonaro que hacía una gestión de la
política exterior ideológica como si
hiciera una gestión interna no viendo
aliados y a enemigos a nivel
internacional y ignorando por ejemplo la
balanza comercial las relaciones
comerciales que tenía Brasil con
nuestros países
ludas seguramente no lo va a hacer y va
a mantener buen diálogo con cualquier
tipo de país y con cualquier tipo de
gobierno tanto sean
gobiernos autoritarios tanto de
izquierda como de derecha o democracias
en todo el mundo claro y Pablo su
opinión sobre lo que puede Brasil
ofrecer a nivel internacional para
volver a ser un actor importante y
destacado de la región y en el mundo
Bueno yo creo que está claro que
tendremos una política exterior mucho
más activa de lo que ha sido en los
últimos 10 años ya todavía con el
gobierno Dilma Brasil empezó a perder un
poco de espacio internacional después
con temer eso sí digo más o menos igual
y un bolsonaro ha sido una política
exterior en efecto muy muy ideológica un
desastre completo nos hemos apartado de
vecinos importantísimos como Argentina y
esto es absolutamente inadmisible para
un país que tiene el peso que tiene
Brasil en la región y en el mundo
Entonces en lo que se espera a partir es
un activismo mucho más importante en
términos de política exterior una mirada
mucho más atenta a la región a los
vecinos apoyan el efecto la integración
regional latinoamericana que se ha
quedado muy de lado y olvidada en los
últimos años y claro intentar establecer
diálogos con todos los países Brasil
tiene una característica un principio
muy claro en política exterior que es
del universalismo relacionarse con todos
son países del medio oriente de Europa
con Estados Unidos con democracias con
dictaduras relaciones con todos porque
eso es lo que claro puede dar a Brasil
un piso internacional importante y sobre
los dictadores latinoamericanos los
gobiernos no tan democráticos en la
región pues estoy Completamente de
acuerdo con Leonardo yo creo que Brasil
en efecto con Luna no va a condenar
directamente a ningún presidente porque
tiene por principio también no
involucrarse en cuestiones domésticas en
política interna de los demás países
Brasil defiende la democracia es un país
democrático siempre lo deja claro pero
Brasil no puede involucrarse en procesos
políticos de otros países entonces
seguramente No veremos ninguna condena
más dura ni a maduro
Ortega ya vamos un poco más allá de la
mitad del programa quiero que ahora
pasemos a analizar a la figura del
contrincante en las urnas el presidente
Jair bolsonaro que aspiraba a tener una
reelección Leonardo que interpretación o
qué análisis se ser del Silencio que ha
tenido bolsonaro frente a los resultados
que tanto tiene de esto táctica política
estrategia un poco al estilo Trump de
mantenerse por fuera de estos resultados
y cómo entender esa actitud de cuando la
democracia está a mi favor yo la
defiendo pero cuando no me funciona en
mi línea entonces la pisoteo
Sí esta es la línea típica de
aspirantes adictadores no bolso
con un golpe de estado un autogolpe en
este caso muchas veces no Y esta actitud
claro se especula mucho no sobre eso
sobre el por el porqué del Silencio si
está planeando un golpe con la cúpula
militar se está
intentando se va a huir del país
pero creo que
es una estrategia más para mantener
cuestionado su electorado no está una
vez más atrayendo la atención sobre sí
siendo disruptivo en la comunicación
política
para mantener un poco su electorado
cautivo alrededor del ideal que tiene no
que en realidad son ideales
no solamente de extrema derecha también
pues autoritario
lo máximo de niveles claro y Pablo qué
lectura se puede hacer de los resultados
la diferencia solamente de 1,8% bolsonar
obtuvo 58 un poco más de 58 millones de
votos es muy significativo para él como
figura política y también para la
derecha y ultraderecha en brasileña este
resultado qué lectura se puede hacer
pero la lectura es que el bolsonarismo
es un fenómeno político muy preocupante
y que hay que tener en cuenta para los
próximos años yo puedo decir que el
bolsonarismo ya es más grande que el
propio bolsonador es algo que vamos va a
continuar en Brasil en los próximos años
la cantidad de votos ha sido
absolutamente impresionante
Entonces es un fenómeno político nuevo
porque no no se relaciona con lo que es
la derecha tradicional brasileña La
centro derecho tradicional es un
fenómeno de ultraderecha radical en
muchas cuestiones sobre todo en lo que
vamos se refiere a la agenda de
costumbres hay un radicalismo que
refleja mucho el carácter conservador de
la sociedad brasileña Donde ha habido en
los últimos años son avance importante
del peso de las iglesias evangélicas en
la política Entonces el bolsonarismo hoy
ya podemos decir después de la Derrotado
ayer es más grande que el proporcionado
algo parecido a lo que ha sucedido en
Estados Unidos con el trampismo que
también Vamos allá del propio Donald
Trump porque lo que se puede analizar y
lo que uno ve entre los comentarios de
analistas y politólogos brasileños es
que a pesar de haber perdido en los
comicios bolsonaros sale en cierta forma
fortalecido porque incluso Tuvo más
votos en la primera ronda y en esta
segunda de lo que las mismas encuestas
le daban Pablo continuó con ustedes ya
le voy a dar la palabra a Leonardo
Quiero preguntarle Pablo muy puntual
entonces la derecha brasileña Cómo se va
a reinventar cómo se va a reevaluar va a
ser oposición Qué actitud va a tomar
para este nuevo gobierno de Lula
bueno la derecha más radical la Ultra
derecha el bolsonarismo claro que va a
ser una oposición muy dura y va a
intentar hacer con que el gobierno de
Luna pues no sea gobernable que sea un
fracaso completo y eso solo alrededor de
los 100 diputados que el personalismo
radical tiene el parlamento pero a la
derecha más tradicional Y con esa Sí yo
creo que no la puede establecer diálogos
importantes de partidos como el mdb el
propio país TV que se ha debilitado
mucho en estas elecciones pero todavía
no es un partido que tiene historia que
tiene su importancia Entonces cuando
Pensamos la derecho brasileña hay un
bloque de partidos que no piensan de la
misma manera y hay muchas diferencias
entre ellos hay partidos de derecha que
son muy tradicionales y que apoyan la
democracia el diálogo y que algunos
incluso pueden hacerlo oposición a Lula
Claro que sí el juego democrático pero
estarán abiertos al diálogo y del otro
lado le tenemos el bolsonarismo más
radical la derecha más radical Entonces
cuando pensamos en lo que será la
política brasileña a partir de ahora hay
que hacer que hay muchos partidos en el
parlamento brasileño menos de los que
había hace cuatro años pero todavía hay
muchos partidos hay una Ultra derecha
muy radical que se ha fortalecido
muchísimo convulsionado y que ha ganado
mucho pies en las elecciones del pasado
2 de octubre pero también hay espacio
para el centro yo creo ahí Entonces
vamos a ver Lula dejemos jugando de
manera Más directa a Lula se ha acercado
mucho ese centro Pablo
porque ya me queda pocos minutos dejemos
el tema del centro para abordarlo en
unos minutos Quiero preguntarle a
Leonardo por el tipo de discurso de
bolsonaro antes de meterme para hablar
de los partidos del centro y lo que
viene para ellos hablar del discurso Tal
parece que al presidente aspirante a la
reelección no le funcionó ese discurso
de desacreditar al ts
hablar mal de las instituciones
brasileñas y sobre todo hacer uso de la
maquinaria del Estado En beneficio de su
propia campaña Esto es algo que también
se ha visto en otros países de América
Latina la estrategia en este caso pues
no funcionó lo demuestran
en realidad Santiago
voy a recordar de usted en ese punto
porque creo que le funcionó muy bien no
Y eso se conecta a lo que estaba
diciendo en un par de preguntas antes no
esta extrema derecha
sobrevive y prospera gracias al hecho de
que hoy en Brasil y en otros países
también es la única fuerza
antisistema con un discurso antisistema
como discurso de revolucionar lo que
tenemos de cambiar radicalmente las
instituciones qué es lo que las
izquierdas han perdido no Entonces le
funcionó muy bien y bolsonaro casi Claro
pues 1% más uno coma algo hubiera podido
ganar esta elección no y realmente salió
fortalecido Tuvo una un resultado
muy bueno en los Estados en el senado en
los Estados y también en Congreso
Nacional
a nivel de discurso quizás
si él ellos no ellos si ellos no fueran
tan brutos No porque se equivocaron en
algunas cosas exageraron quizás en
algunos elementos quizás hubieran
poniendo vencer nuevamente no y es una
razón por la que en las encuestas
cualquier pequeño error que cometía duda
en el discurso lo potencialmente Incluso
en los estudios cualitativos que
realizamos no hacía caer no sin embargo
funcionaron con los disparates más
grandes lograba mantenerse siempre Claro
en su mismo nivel me quedan muy pocos
minutos Paulo hablemos de la derecha lo
habíamos dejado sobre la mesa la derecha
tuvo poco protagonismo en en estas
elecciones no logró pasar a esta segunda
vuelta y por eso vemos este escenario
tan polarizado en el en la segunda
vuelta pero vemos a un presidente electo
pasándole a un frente un poco más amplio
podrá ser el inicio de una consagración
de una de unos partidos de centro de un
movimiento de Centro que muchos
brasileños están pidiendo
Sí sí yo creo que eso ya es una realidad
si miramos a lo que han sido estas
elecciones hemos visto a luna eligiendo
como vicepresidente un político
tradicionalmente de centro de derecha
Gerardo alekmin que incluso ha disputado
elecciones contra el PT hemos visto en
segunda vuelta Simone tévez ha sido
candidata por el mdb otro partido muy
tradicional desde la redemocracia
también un partido más de Centro centro
de derecha apoyando directamente a Lula
Entonces yo creo que en una ha
conseguido juntar aglutinar un nombres
importantes y partidos importantes que
quieren defender la democracia y que no
necesariamente estarán siempre a su lado
y que van seguramente también a cobrar
mucho de lo que ha prometido Pero esto
significa algo muy positivo para la
gobernabilidad en Brasil para la
democracia en Brasil y para el futuro
político del país porque solamente así
conseguiremos neutralizar lo que
significa el bolsonalismo y todos los
ataques que han sido hechos contra la
democracia en el país en los últimos
cuatro años llegamos al momento de las
conclusiones al cierre del programa
Leonardo su perspectiva de lo que deja
Esta carrera presidencial este nuevo
presidente que llega al país y se habrá
una transición tranquila el primero de
enero
muy puntual por favor pues ganó la
democracia y ahora la real lucha empieza
no Ya empezó y sigue y tiene que ser una
lucha principalmente cultural y
civilizatoria en contra de la mentalidad
autoritaria de la mentalidad fascista y
Pablo su conclusión para el cierre
Bueno yo no creo que tengamos una
transición tan tranquila Yo creo que
estos últimos meses van a ser
complicados para Brasil bolsonaro va a
intentar poner las cosas aún más
difíciles de lo que ya están para el
nuevo gobierno el simple hecho de no
haber reconocido la victoria Y eso es un
indicativo de que tiene un despecho
absoluto por la democracia y que no va a
hacer una transición que sea Pacífico
tranquila esperemos que a partir del 9
de enero todo esto ya sea pasado y
Brasil prueba pueda volver a crecer y
crecer de manera estable sostenible de
un país más Unido pero no Será algo
sencillo Pablo Leonardo Muchas gracias
por haber compartido con nosotros su
análisis y su punto de vista sobre estas
elecciones presidenciales en Brasil en
nombre de todo el equipo técnico Les
agradecemos su sintonía aquí en France
24 la producción del programa estuvo a
cargo de Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados estuvo a carga de Tania
Herrera gracias por su sintonía sigan
con Franz 24
[Música]